mental health was getting worse once
they started the blocker and that's
against what the narrative tells us the
narrative says these interventions are
supposed to make people better we were
pretty much putting anybody on
testosterone at 13 and a half if that's
what they wanted it was getting to the
point where we were harming more
patients that we were helping
just by the Numbers what I am not in
agreement with is this push to Rapid
medicalization of children and it got to
the point in the center where
there was a an actual directive
that we were no longer allowed to use
the phrase I have concerns about a
patient and in medicine that should
scare
anyone
foreign
[Music]
I'm Francis Foster I'm Constantine
kitchen and this is a show for you if
you want honest conversations with
Fascinating People a very special guest
today is a whistleblower from a
transgender clinic in the United States
Jamie Reed welcome to trigonometry thank
you for having me uh it's great to have
you on the show listen uh Francis and I
have just both reread your article for a
second time uh we're going to talk about
all the stuff that you said in there one
of the most terrifying things that I've
ever read to be honest and so I'm
looking forward to speaking with you
about it but before we get into that uh
just tell our audience who may not be
familiar with you and and the story that
you shared who are you what's been your
journey through life how did you get to
the position that you got to and what
did you see there and why did you decide
to speak up
thank you for those questions so um I'm
Jamie Reed I have a masters of Science
in clinical research management and I
was previously the caseworker in the
Pediatric transgender Center at a clinic
in St Louis Missouri so in the middle of
the middle of America
um I started well I spent about four
years and four months in that position I
worked at the University previous to
working with trans kids I was working
with young adults who were HIV positive
I have a lot of experience in case
management I worked with kids who are in
foster care
um and I've also worked in a lot of
medical and health settings too
so I came into the clinic really excited
about the opportunity that I thought was
going to be to help trans Youth and
their parents
and you mentioned in your article that
you know you're very Progressive you're
married to a trans man like or in a
relationship with a trans man sorry I
don't remember which but in any case
you're married well congratulations so
very Progressive you know you come into
this place wanting to make a difference
I assume and then over a period of time
you start to have doubts and you try to
express doubts and that doesn't go
particularly well for you and
increasingly you become very alarmed at
what you're seeing so talk to us you
know just at the very beginning of that
Germany you get there I'm sure you're
all pumped and ready to go and what
happens
right away I was struck by
the lack of organization for the center
so there was no real written protocols
it seemed like it was kind of a fly by
the seat of the pants kind of operation
they had already been open for a solid
year before I got there and yet it
seemed like they were kind of operating
outside of a lot of the normal
structures that you'd see in medicine
most of the Departments and divisions in
medicine have a lot of layers there's a
lot of top heavy there's a lot of you
know administrative roles and it seemed
like the center was kind of
off on its own
had this little pocket and I was also
struck at the very beginning because the
administration of this hospital let this
Clinic open
and I was told that they originally
thought that they were going to have
about 50 patients total
and when I left
we were close to 2000.
wow yeah huge difference
and why do you think that was Jamie what
do you think were the reasons for that
um I definitely have come to believe
that in the United States there is an
element of social contagion in play
going on with young people who are
seeking out care in gender centers and
I'm not the only one to believe that I
had lots of parents report very similar
things and there were even a number of
patients in the center who would report
and directly said I I only got this
online
wow so they only got this online because
your article is very interesting because
you talk about when you started in the
center it was mainly boys suffering from
gender dysphoria and then you started to
see more and more girls come in
were they the ones who were particularly
to success susceptible to this social
contagion as you put it
I think it's well known in medicine that
adolescent girls are just more
a more open and more susceptible to many
different kinds of social contagions
that has to do with a lot of ways that
girls are socialized but also the way
that girls interact in kind of group
settings and pick up things and show
empathy with those in their group
setting oftentimes by taking on
attributes in those group settings
so I didn't just see that these kids
were picking up gender as a social
contagion we have a lot of issues right
now in my country with adolescents who
are experiencing
tick disorders they think they have
Tourette's there's been a recent wave of
young people believing that they have
what they refer to as did so multiple
personalities
you are seeing these things directly
coming from social media
and Jamie can I ask you a question and
sorry to sort of appear picky but before
you started talking about how adolescent
girls have certain problems you kind of
did like a little sigh almost like
you're resigning yourself to having to
say is it was part of your experience
that even that very idea was
controversial in the environment that
you were operating in
um
so
you'll have to
remember that in some ways I am
deep programming my language out of some
cult like
conversations so even for me I still
take pause in using the phrase
adolescent girls because when you work
in a place like this you don't say that
you say people are assigned female at
Birth
you don't say people are boys you say
they are signed male at Birth so even
the way that we spoke about everybody
was in this
framework of the gender ideology world
wow
so just I know that to you this seems
kind of like normal but so not like a
person outside of that space just to
clarify in this transgender Clinic you
would never refer to people as boys or
girls or men or women you would say
assigned female at birth that's
transphobic to do so
wow
okay
but so yeah so so but even though
biological sex is obviously real
oh yes
um medicine
is
is really interesting in this right now
because
in some ways all of the doctors would
clearly acknowledge biological sex we
would uh you would say someone was
assigned female birth assigned male at
Birth maybe you could use natal sex
um they they acknowledged its existence
because in you know if you're in the
emergency room and you have somebody
who's coding and you're trying to figure
out
you know what their lung capacity is you
know there are definite medical needs
and times when your biological sex
changes the course of the treatment
um but in our patient population we
everyone was
assigned female birth assigned male at
Birth you heard the term CIS a lot who's
cisgender we talked about how all of our
patients were probably you know would
judge you if you walked in and they
thought you were CIS
um those kind of things it's it's
is constant
and Jamie how did this affect this type
of language how did this affect the way
that you treated your patients
I do think that um
the staff were always
sort of on edge
because it wasn't just the concern that
you were providing good medical care but
you also always had the concern
has this patient's pronouns changed
again
their preferred names were changing
frequently even the term preferred name
sometimes people would say that's not
that's you know activists would push
that that you can't even say that
because it's not it's not their
preference it's their name even though
it's not their legal name
um
a lot of the staff that are hired into
the clinics like this at least in the
United States are also activists and
oftentimes directly there's a push to
directly hire
trans and lgbtqia people to work in
these clinics as the staff
and so you joined the clinic you start
working you start noticing some of these
things and when did you start to get
really concerned because you were the
person responsible for processing the
intake of potential patients so you're
getting these people in and going you go
here you go there
when did you feel like whoa like this is
not good
it was a slow process to get there
um there definitely was a point where I
went from 10 intakes a month where there
would be 10 newly referred young people
to
the numbers being in the 40s and 50s
every single month and
the cases were getting
more and more outlandish or sometimes
even completely
bizarre
in the states oftentimes if anything
about gender gets brought up in a
pediatrician's office they immediately
just refer you to the gender Center so I
could be getting an intake where a kid
maybe told their parent three days ago
that they thought they were non-binary
and asking for they them pronouns and
yet they're already Landing in a
specialized Medical Clinic that does
hormones
so there were some intakes where it was
just it made absolutely no sense the
entire concept of kids being allowed to
explore their gender and explore these
Concepts have been almost wiped off the
map
and what would happen let's say I bring
my 12 year old daughter to you three
days ago she said that she's non-binary
she wants there them pronouns what
happens to her from there
so initially I would try to be
encouraging you as a parent to find a
therapist and start working with
therapists for your kid
um
but
the minute you're talking to me on the
phone you have already started on a
pathway
because the only therapists that I have
to refer your kid to
our therapists who are going to affirm
their gender identity not question it at
all and potentially as soon as I say
take your kid to that therapist that
therapist might see them for one or two
visits and send them right back to the
center to get started and seen by the
people that prescribe hormones
so three days ago my daughter said I
think I'm non-binary because she saw on
social media let's say I bring her to
you you send this to a therapist therapy
sees us a couple of times sends us back
to you in order to see a doctor to be
prescribed hormones
potentially yes
Jesus [__] Christ sorry for my
language okay yeah so I
I think this is a very important part of
the conversation because
someone I know very close to me had a
double mastectomy and that is a very
very serious operation it's a very
serious operation it could and you know
but this better than anyone it can take
months to recover from and actually the
risk of complications with such an
invasive type of surgery uh the risks
are high to put it moldy
so let's look at this what do we mean by
puberty blockers what do we mean by
these drugs and what are the potential
side effects of these drugs
so the puberty blockers we were using
were mostly their implants that go into
the arm or their injectables that are
used on a monthly or three month basis
um in our Center you had to be at least
in the very initial start of puberty to
get a puberty blocker
um but one of the things we were
starting to see was that some of the
kids put on the puberty blockers mental
health was getting worse once they
started the blocker and that's against
what the narrative tells us the
narrative says these interventions are
supposed to make people better and what
we were seeing was parents calling and
saying my child has had the Blocker in
for a month they're crying every day
they've had the Blocker in for three
months and they're now failing out of
school
um things that were supposed to be
gutter getting better were getting worse
in the center that I worked in
I started there when we were still
supposed to be operating Under The W
path
guidelines standard of care seven which
had some age kind of
ideas for when people were supposed to
start hormones
um wpath 7 was supposed to be 16 and it
said only in rare and you know kind of
urgent cases should you be under the age
of 16. we were pretty much putting
anybody on testosterone at 13 and a half
if that's what they wanted and they got
to us in time and what does that do to
you if you are a young person who's been
given testosterone
young girl well it depends so if you
your female assigned a birth sorry well
no even if you were given a blocker
first okay and we blocked you and then
put you on a cross-sex hormone we are
potentially
basically
causing you to be infertile for life
and testosterone
um
you know the the effects that kids
reported that they wanted
happen pretty quick so we would
permanently affect your voice and your
voice would be dropped into a male pitch
you would see growth on your clitoris
into what we would refer to as a micro
penis
um we would start seeing atrophy and
your vaginal Canal would start to have
atrophic features
your
all of your body fat would start to move
and shift around you would have facial
hair growth a lot of our patients would
start to start losing the hair on the
top of their head
um and then
we would see mood changes we would see
patients who were
again they're supposed to be getting
better their mental health was supposed
to be getting better A lot of times it
was not doing what we thought it was
going to do and if you were on
feminizing hormones you would start
growing breast tissue your fat would
move
um and again if you were put on blockers
first it would render you potentially
infertile for life and now we also know
for
the kids the the boys if we block you
and put you on feminizing hormones we
also are potentially making you have
sexual dysfunction for life
what do you mean by sexual dysfunction
so in the boys
blockers make it so that they never grow
the penis or the testicles
if you never go through
puberty and you never have those
hormones affect that area you are left
with the same kind of penis size that
you would have that kids have when
they're little before they go through
puberty
and then also
we knew that the feminizing hormones
would make it so you had a lot of
erectile dysfunction the testicles would
shrink and atrophy
and we would be
causing changes to that part of the body
that were irreversible
I hate to State the obvious but those
are some pretty major changes for a
young person to undergo an experience
and the fact that
a young person
could have that start happening to them
after seeing a therapist twice in an
endocrinologist once to me does not
ethically line up
hey Constantine do you like being
healthy of course in my country we judge
Men's Health by his ability to wrestle
bear turns out in London Russell bear
has very different meaning
let's go out of hand
[Applause]
we will speak no more of this the secret
will be buried with my ancestors well if
you want to stay healthy and not feel
like you need to be buried with
Constantine's ancestors then you need to
try ag1 ag1 is simple and easy way to
get all nutrients you need each serving
contains 75 high quality vitamins
minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients one scoop and you feel like
real men we use it on our America Tour
where we were constantly on the Move
living out of a bag and working every
day ag1 meant we felt great look great
and we avoided getting sick one scoop a
day meant we knew we had all the
vitamins and minerals needed for the day
we had hugely successful trip it is very
economical and I felt strong enough to
wrestle American bird which we all know
is grotesly weak compared to Great
Russian word if you're looking for a
simpler and cost effective supplement
routine 81 is giving you a free one year
is supply of vitamin D and five travel
packs with your first purchase go into
athleticgreens.com
trigonometry that athleticrings.com
trigonometry check it out and become
real men like me
one of the other things that we should
also talk about is it came to a point
you talked about in your article that
sometimes there were situations
particularly if it went to court if
parents disagreed about this that you
had a situation that you talk about
where the mother who was quite Disturbed
based on your recollection at least
insisted that her daughter who wasn't
particularly a typical case of someone
who experiencing genuine desire to
transition was encouraged to transition
by her mother against her father's
wishes and the center where you worked
for was essentially the one that was
giving the recommendation to the judge
and made the recommendation that it
should be the mother's opinion that that
essentially comes out on top so a parent
was in a situation where the child was
going through all of this
without even consenting to it
right we we had that happen quite
frequently and right now in the United
States it seems like in the courts
the parents who want to give these drugs
are the ones that are winning in the
custody cases
which to me
oh it just
oftentimes the parents who didn't want
to give the drugs all they were asking
for was more time in therapy and even
I they were losing they're losing in
court and I think in part because
doctors like the doctors that worked in
my Center would show up in court and
testify on behalf of the parent who
wanted to give the drugs right away
why is that
uh why would they do that because
it's the part of the ideological
mindset that the thought is is that we
have to give these drugs right away or
else uh
or else these kids are gonna be harmed
somehow
and you say ideological is there not
evidence to say that you know if you get
in there early you can say that's the
argument that people make you know you
get in there early you save them the
discomfort of later life developing you
know the anatomy of their birth sex Etc
is there evidence for this idea
um not in the kinds of patients that are
presenting currently
and it depends so if you look back at
the original study it's often referred
to as the Dutch study if you look back
at the original study they were
screening outpatients who had mental
health concerns because the goal of that
treatment
was yes to treat some dysphoria but
there's not evidence that this treats
major depressive disorder borderline
personality disorder autism
that's that's not what this is evidence
to treat and yet the argument is is that
if we can medicalize somebody then all
of their other mental health issues will
somehow be alleviated
and the reason you mentioned that sorry
France no just to clarify this is that a
lot of the new cases that you saw over
and above what you expected these were
very different profiles they were not
boys they were young girls who were
presenting with eating disorders autism
autism-like symptoms Etc right that's
why you bring it up absolutely and they
are and they are girls who often times
there is a disagreement so they will
claim that oh I felt like this my whole
life and their parents initially will
often say they had no gender issues at
all as a child that they were absolutely
normatively fine in their being a girl
and it onset
um
at 10 11 12 13 14 15.
what you were saying is completely
antithetical to
the the Creed that doctors are supposed
to follow which is Do no harm
what what you're saying and what I'm
hearing is that it harm being inflicted
on children which is appalling
yes that's what I came to finally
understand that maybe maybe
out of our huge number of patients there
were a few patients that this model of
care maybe helped but it was getting to
the point where we were harming more
patients that we were helping
just by the numbers
wow and so why at that point when
goes with autism I think you quoted the
number of 30 percent of presenting
themselves the 30 of autistic goers when
people with severe psychiatric illnesses
are presenting themselves and I'll be
putting through transition including
some of the awful case that you've
spoken about why hasn't there been more
people coming out and and talking about
this or more people wanting to stop this
so I do think those people that I think
that there are more people like me
and I I know that I've spoken to a
number of them since I have come forward
but if you even look at what has
happened to me in my own local press
those
basically the voice of reason the voice
of can we slow down the voice of we need
to actually look at who we're hurting is
being drowned out right now and we're
being shouted down and screamed out by
this idea that the fact that I say
anything is somehow
is gonna hurt and harm
trans kids
so what has been the treatment that
you've received from the local press
um I can
I can't even count the number of
Articles and all they do is have
vilified me
um and they also vilify me in in strange
ways where I just wonder
a lot of America right now is liking to
pretend like y'all and England don't
exist or that Sweden doesn't exist or
Finland doesn't exist or nor none of the
countries like your country that's
actually
starting to have some kind of a dialogue
around this all the local media would
like to think that America is in its own
bubble and we know it's right on this
topic and no one else exists well I I
just the reason I ask is we've spoken to
a lot of people about this issue from
all sorts of different angles and the
usual stuff is their transfer whatever
but you're married to a trans man how
transphobic can you be
uh I also had identified as genderqueer
in the past and I experienced a lot of
gender dysphoria as a child myself
um I am I'm not opposed to adult
transitioning
um
I do still think that adults who are
transitioning would benefit by support
of a therapist and a therapeutic process
but I am not in any way opposed to trans
people I also have an undergrad in
anthropology I fully understand that
there is a lot of diversity in
um gender and gender presentation but
what I am not in agreement with is this
push to Rapid medicalization of children
and also
the current
model doesn't even
it doesn't even make sense if you're
actually Pro
diversity because if if I am pro-gender
diversity why are we telling little kids
that if they play with a toy that is not
in their gender category that somehow
that means that they're trans like I
thought it's 2023 shouldn't we be
telling our children you can wear
whatever you want you can play with
whatever toys you want you can have
whatever job you want and instead we've
we're in some like weird 1950s thing
where if a boy plays with a Barbie
suddenly his parents think that he needs
to go to a gender clinic and it means
that they're trans
do you know the thing that I find quite
unusual as well is that in a society
like America which is so litigious where
people super others at the drop of a hat
you have the you have the minimum of
medical checks false Tracking not only
people but children
and you're in some very young children
at that through to irreversible medical
procedures
I mean that's just I mean that's just a
million dollar lawsuit wanting to happen
isn't it no because
um unfortunately the
the
institutions that are supposed to
okay let me explain so if you go and try
to file that lawsuit in the United
States today
the doctors and the hospitals are able
to say that the American Academy of
Pediatrics says that this is right the
endocrine society says this is right and
they try to they can just claim that
they're just following
all of these Medical
guidelines
um
I I did not believe that where I worked
was following even these quote
guidelines but judges I think thus far
have been
taking that at that easy face value I
mean you hear it in the news well the
American you know all of the American
medical establishments agree with this
kind of care
and
I it doesn't line up
no it doesn't and I suppose just to give
people an example of what you're talking
about you talking in your article about
a case where there was a girl who had a
double mastectomy she had a breast
removed I think it's 16 uh if I'm
remembering correctly around that time
sorry go ahead and correct me if no I
think if if you're talking about the
patient who called a few months later
and asked to have her breakfast put back
on she was not a minor but she was young
she was 18 or 19 when we did the surgery
so she has her breast removed a few
months later she calls up and says I'm a
girl I want my breasts back I mean a
horrifying story in and of itself and
she's pregnant
so she's not going to be able to
breastfeed her child the most horrific
thing I think one of the most horrific
things that could happen to a young
woman
you're saying she can't sue the people
who advised her and put her through that
I'm not a lawyer successful I'm not a
lawyer so I don't know yeah there is
potentially a case there but I know that
um the way that the surgeons and the way
that the center responded was that she
made the choice
yeah and I think we see that with the
detransitioners and some of them are
minors and they will say well your
parent made the choice
and that's kind of the question here
isn't it because one of the most
mind-boggling things about this ideology
as you describe it is uh you know I I am
myself not a progressive uh I'm I'm also
somewhere in the middle but I thought
one of the most Central elements of
progressivism was this increased
attention towards the idea of consent
people shouldn't do things uh you know
to other people without their consent
but I don't know about anyone but it
doesn't seem to me like a 15 year old or
16 year old frankly even an 18 year old
from a very troubled background like
this young woman is really capable of
consenting to those things
with you know a full proper
understanding of the impact
these kids want these things
so in
so in these family Dynamics and in these
centers
these kids show up and they were
demanding this from their parents
yesterday and their whole household has
been in chaos because this kid has
decided that the best thing for them
right now is to start testosterone
tomorrow
and
I don't even know
how you can okay part of medical ethics
and part of actual consenting has to be
that you're not
under any undue influence
so
we think about that sometimes in in
really you know bad medical case like if
you were just told you have cancer
and you in its potentially you know a
very bad cancer we don't want to tell
you 10 minutes later would you like to
be in this research study for this drug
because we're putting you in an undue
influence and sometimes we even say
maybe you're uh maybe the person who's
going to treat your cancer shouldn't be
the person who asks you if you want to
do this procedure it should be somebody
neutral so you're you know so we think
about these things in medical ethics
in medical ethics those young people I
believe are in a situation where they
have undue influence they are being
influenced by a socially mediated
cultural phenomenon and the only way
that they truly could give consent to
that treatment is if they have been out
of that phenomenon and out of that
social pressure for long enough I.E
potentially an adult to then provide
that real consent or or we could just
you know shut off all social media and
tell them they can't look at this stuff
and then ask them you know if you have a
if you have a 15 year old girl who's in
the middle of this belief and we put her
in the middle of Montana with no
internet access on a horse farm
she potentially might not want
testosterone 12 months down the line but
that's the level they're they're under
so much influence it's from their school
it's from their peers it's from the
social media and they want this right
now
that makes sense but Jamie on top of all
of that though
it's a kind of basic principle of our
societies the children can't consent to
anything really
right you can't you can't drink or take
drugs or have sex lots of other much
more uh much less significant things in
terms of the impact on your life and the
lives of other people around you you
can't get a bad tattoo and be sick about
it you have to be 18 to get bad tattoos
so you can get a tattoo you can't get a
tattoo but you can get you can get
hormones and potentially double
mastectomy is it because I'm not is that
just I mean sorry but is that not insane
it
it is to me now
it was not to me then I'm not having a
go at you I'm trying to flesh out the
issue itself do you see what I'm saying
yeah no I yeah
I get it
and join me again there's no blame
attached to this what we're trying to do
is we're just trying to understand
how these places work and you say it
wasn't obvious to you
why was that
so many of the
the people who worked who I worked with
and I think that a lot of the people
that work in these centers and in
medicine and in Pediatrics in general
have a huge heart they really do care
and they really do think that this is
the way to help
these kids and I also think that when
you
are faced with
so much distress
so much chaos these kids are hurting
they are maybe saying that they're
suicidal that they're self-harming that
they are they are struggling
I think on some level it's easier to say
well we'll give you what you want then
to stand up and be the grown-up and say
no we're not doing that right now and
instead we have to do other things and
then we also have to support the parents
because
if you have parents who have been trying
to deal with their kid who's been
demanding testosterone demanding this
new name demanding these new pronouns
demanding these clothes and this and
these kids are telling their parents
it's the only thing that's going to keep
me from killing myself
how do we support those parents to also
say no we need to slow down and we need
to think about this
do you think part of the problem is and
I'm going to go back to the litigious
point is that these clinics are worried
that if they don't do something and then
let's say the kid does something
rational you know what you know tries to
kill themselves that they are then going
to be held responsible for not putting
correct interventions in place because
someone will come to them and go look
this kid said they were suicidal they
said they were gender dysphoric you
chose not you chose not to give the
correct procedures so we just call it
like that in place as a result this kid
attempted suicide you're at fault
So my answer is complicated here so I've
worked with young people who are
expressing suicidal ideations thoughts
for a really long time
I am not
trying to downplay suicidal thoughts and
trans kids
but
I saw more
suicides in kids within the foster care
system and kids who were HIV positive as
a young person
than we saw in the Pediatric gender
Center
and
a lot of the kids and the gender Center
their Suicidal Thoughts
are different
so oftentimes when we would send them
these are seen more as
threats and not attempts that's not to
say that we didn't have patients who did
have true suicidal ideations
but
I think as a whole the statistics do not
show that there are
that
High numbers of completed suicides in
this
and very much on that subject and I know
it's a tricky thing to ask you but I
feel like I should we've heard from
other guests that quite often because
this this idea of being trans or
whatever is social media driven
the kids are actually getting
instructions on how to talk to somebody
like you absolutely to get what they to
get what they need so that when you know
not all of them but some of them are
coming in and saying oh I'm suicidal
because they know that's what gets the
thing that they want is that happening
it is but the thing that scares me a
little bit too is that some of the
parents are doing the same thing
so I had some parents who would call to
complete an intake with me and they
would describe the situation and I would
say hey
from what you're describing it sounds
like your kid is just experiencing some
normal gender questioning it does not
warrants
the need to be seen in a gender Center
and then they would sometimes press me
and find out kind of well what are the
things that warrant you being seen in a
gender Center
and then
magically mom would call me back
a month later and now suddenly kiddo has
expressed exactly what I told Mom
was needed to meet that
criteria
we even had I had Parents even tell me
things like
my kid likes to play with this toy and
then they would tell me that they went
and bought all of the kids books they
could find on Amazon about being trans
and that they had hidden and sprinkled
the trans kids books all throughout the
house
for their kids to find
and those were cases that just
there's something going on
and what I know it's unfair to ask you
to speculate about other people's
intentions but do you have any sense of
why a parent would want to do that
I think you had a guest on maybe before
who talked a little bit about how you
know to be a really to be a truly good
liberal parent right now
is to kind of
allow your kid to
it's like gone so far in One Direction
where you know if your kid expresses the
slightest
non -gender tight role you know you
immediately need to start affirming and
asking them I mean I had Parents talk
about how they would have all their kids
close their eyes in like a circle in
their house in some like
weird seancy thing and then open their
eyes and tell us what your inner gender
is now
so this is parents literally seeding
these ideas into the heads of their own
children yes
uh my question is uh and by the way just
for clarification I don't know if you
know this I was a teacher for a long
time and I taught across all sectors and
I taught in girls schools as well so I
saw how social contagion work
particularly with young girls uh when I
taught in girls schools it was late
naughty so back then there wasn't really
any of the trans stuff it was mainly
anorexia
but I look at this and I go
that's child abuse
that is child abuse because if I was a
teacher and I heard that this was being
done to a kid who I was teaching I would
report them to Social Services
that would be my duty as a teacher in
the UK and if I didn't do that I would
not I
I would not be fulfilling my role I
would not be as we called in the UK in
loco parentis
yes and there were a few cases where I
would agree with you
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
and that is also part of the problem in
the media right now
because
oftentimes the parents that are so
gung-ho to talk to the news about how
this saved their kids life and how their
kid is doing so well are like these
really hardcore activist parents who
bought all the way in and
they're the ones drum beating this too
and
why is this ideology so powerful why is
it that it can take hold of people like
this so the point that they do this to
their own children and and create not
significant long-term harm
who
um
so in
in the liberal view right now in the
United States
there is this
huge kind so to be a white person in the
United States with privilege and to be
middle class and to be able to afford
things for your kids and to be able to
kind of
to be in this privileged position is
seen as a negative for a lot of liberal
people and so I do feel like being
trans has become this thing that you
can't question
so you you can't really easily change
you can't say you're of A different race
in the United States you can't claim
ethnic background if you don't have it
you can't I mean who's going to claim
that they're poor I mean
and if you if you identify it is
a or lesbian you know that's
uncomfortable pretty quickly if you
if you're not really gay or lesbian but
for these young people you can claim
that you're non-binary and throw they
them pronouns up and and suddenly you're
in the
you're in the group that's no longer the
oppressor you are in the oppressed group
and I think part of why this says such
these strong tentacles is nobody in my
country ever wants to tell somebody
who's in
you know what we view as an oppressive
group
that they're not and nobody wants to be
seen as the oppressor
and but and I accept that and again this
is there is no blame attached to this
whatsoever I'm just exploring
what about the adults
what about the medical professionals
isn't it their job to make that decision
that's what you went to college for
that's what you studied that's why you
put yourself through a medical degree
that's why you're in that position for
you to make that choice do you see what
I mean
but you
but the culture is so harsh right now
that if they were to say no to a patient
then they were gonna get you're gonna
get blasted on social media that you're
a transphobic doctor
that you
and what does that mean because on
social media your planet is a
transphobic doctor what does that mean
for your career what does that mean for
your prospects what does that mean for
the way people perceive you
um I can speak from my own position
which is that I am the
I am the hated Outsider
um I
um I I was in a very interesting
position to become a whistleblower I'm
basically a Luddite I I
had no social media to speak of I had
nothing to get destroyed or taken away
from me my Twitter I had none of that I
I'm an old school
Luddite and I also was an anarchist in
the 90s and you know I remember the
black block and the WTO protest and I
lived in an anarchist Collective like I
kind of had a really thick skin but I
also remember those kind of politics and
I remember
um
standing up for something and and
knowing that even if you're gonna get
you know everybody pile on you that
that you'll thought that that the other
activists are out there they might be
small and it might be a small group but
but I felt firm enough in my own
internal convictions and I worry that
we're in a culture right now because of
the way social media has changed that
it's so external the judgment is so
external not internal that for so many
people even adults
it takes a lot of strength to to go up
against your dominant culture
it does and that's one of the reasons I
really want to thank you for for coming
out and and talking about this because I
think it's super important and one of
the things we haven't yet talked about
in detail is what happened
internally when you started speaking up
about this because you started to ask
questions didn't you I did um I started
asking questions often and it got to the
point where I even was having
conversations one-on-one with the doctor
saying I we are harming children we are
doing this
um what would they say
so it's interesting because I I only
recently read the Hannah Barnes book
about the Tavistock and I was it was
almost the exact same response which I
was told my tone was wrong that I was I
shouldn't be directly challenging
doctors and team meetings that I was out
of my Lane that I was
um it was almost identical what happened
at Tavistock
um and the way that I was kind of
treated was I was the annoying squeaky
wheel oh we know Jamie's gonna have
another issue and it got to the point in
the center where
there was a an actual directive
that we were no longer allowed to use
the phrase I have concerns about a
patient
and in medicine that should scare
anyone because
if your surgeon comes in and the nurse
thinks that they're drunk
sure as hell that nurse should be able
to say I have concerns about this
patient right now and we need to stop we
need medicine needs people who are
empowered by their Medical Institution
to speak up nurses social workers case
managers you think someone was given the
wrong dose you think they're going to
cut off the wrong limb like you have to
have all of these layers in medicine
have to have people who are empowered
and encouraged to stand up and instead
it was routinely be quiet stop you're
wrong be quiet stop and it got to the
point finally where we were told get on
board or get out and that was
that was the final you say we were the
other people at the center who agreed
with you
we didn't always agree for the same
reasons but there were a few other
people who who agreed okay and you had
the same concerns
yeah and you mentioned speaking directly
one-on-one with doctors so if you come
to a doctor in that sort of clinic and
you would say I think we're harming
these children
would did other than shut up and and
stop raising it did they did they have
any counter arguments or any explanation
for why what they were doing what they
were doing
um
sometimes it would be well what do you
want me to do instead
come up with a different solution then
and I think part of that is that the
whole model of care is so
upside down right now that
it's like every that there that the
doctors are even just a cog in the
spinning machine and they're like the
only way I know how to spin is this way
like you're telling me we're hurting
people but I they would be like what how
do I do differently
because then it would have to stop the
it was almost like for them to actually
stop and think would have to stop the
whole mechanism the whole machine would
have to stop because
it's not just their portion it's the
therapist portion it's the parents
portion it's the kids themselves it's
the hospital it's like all this whole
machine
is spinning and and they were like what
it what do I do and I guess in some ways
I just got to the point where I was like
you know this whole machine just has to
stop right now because
the way that it's going is just it's not
it sort of sounds what you're describing
is like a little bit like a conveyor
belt where it's like yeah right and then
you're going up to one person at one
point and you're going well don't put
this bit in and they're going well
there's a whole machine here there's a
whole conveyor belt you know this is my
job I give hormones or I do this or I do
that right yes exactly and this is what
they call their affirmative model where
essentially the moment a kid says I'm
dysphoric from that point on they're
just on the conveyor belt and there's no
getting off unless as long as a kid
right as long as the kid is saying I
want that as the end then that's what
the kid's gonna get
and you said upside down and that really
is upside down because as we talked
about earlier a child cannot really
consent but they are driving this whole
thing is what you're telling us oh the
the language even in some of the
activist groups is that you're supposed
to be child LED but the child's supposed
to be leading this and here's the thing
about kids
who think that they're the ones for
supposed to make the decision are
actually in more distress and are in
more pain
because they feel like
there's no grown-ups in the room who are
in charge and as a parent I know for my
own kids they do better in life when I
can say things to them like hey
this is not your decision we're the
grown-ups we've got this handled
we know what we're doing you can go be a
kid do not worry about these things and
as they get older you maybe add a little
bit more like no at Disneyland you
cannot buy the whole Toy Store because
grown-ups only have this much money and
you slowly start giving them some senses
of choice but no a 14 year old does not
want to think that they have to make the
decision for what the whole rest of
their life is for their fertility and
for their medical care
no I mean he's absolutely spot on it's
why all this child centered I see I saw
it towards the end of my time in
education they called it child-centered
learning where the child was in charge
of their learning and I was like I don't
think an eight-year-old should be in
charge of their learning it's just I
don't think an eight-year-old should be
in charge of my dinner choice for
tonight because they're not going to
choose I mean no yeah ice cream and
Jello for you tonight yeah Jamie yeah
listen we joke of course but the one
thing look I I became a parent about 11
months ago you know and when I think
about this that's the prison through
which I'm thinking about I've got this
beautiful baby boy he's pure
potentiality he's growing up he's
wonderful and then fast forward a few
years and they fly by and let's say he's
been on Tick Tock or whatever which is
not going to be at this rate but let's
say that he was and we he says that he's
experiencing distress the household is
in turmoil as you describe and we the
good parents take them to professionals
for help mm-hmm
and then three months later he's on
puberty blockers
and estrogen and and in in the case that
you described some of them are taking
like cancer drugs yep yeah
so I mean the question I think parents
would want to ask you Jamie is what
should you do if that is what happens to
your child
I think that's a really good question
and first of all there are a whole lot
of parents out there who can answer this
question also and what I found
frustrating with the media is there are
a lot of parents who wanted to talk to
my local media
because they had a kid in that situation
and they knew better than to take their
kid to the center that I work at they
already figured it out I cannot go there
I cannot take my kid there unless I want
X Y and Z is the outcome
but again parents can be a parent one of
the things that's the caseworker in the
center I found really shocking for a lot
of these parents is you do get to have
some of the control and say over your
child's social media use there are
parental controls uh my poor kids their
cell phones still sleep in the kitchen
you don't you don't have your cell phone
with you in the middle of the night in
your room at 12. that's insane nobody
needs that and the parents would be like
oh well they use sleep music I'm like no
get this put some levers and controls
back in being a parent but also
um
these kids right now are under a lot of
mental health stress and issues and you
need to find a good pediatrician if you
think your kid is expressing you know
anxiety or depression regardless of the
gender focus on those things focus on
the basics these kids are kids who are
not going to school very
well or often need friends groups need
to go outside and get exercise need to
sleep we are seeing that a ton of these
kids had terrible sleep hygiene need to
eat real food I mean some of these
things are from you know the beginnings
the basics as parents as do these
healthy things from the start and then
if your kid does come to you and say
they're experiencing X Y and G things
about their gender my answer is normally
normative gender exploration is fine
wear whatever clothes you want within
reason you still have to be dressed I
don't care what your hair looks like I
don't care if you're a boy and you want
to wear makeup or nail polish who cares
let those social gender things can we
actually like be a little bit more
flexible with those things
let your kids explore but no you don't
need to change everybody's pronouns your
name cannot change 12 times if you want
to nickname fine but no you don't need a
binder you don't need you don't need to
do all of these things and you really do
not need to be medically intervening
let them explore and give them a way out
tell them as the parent explore this
stuff try this on but if you try this
and you don't like it then we can change
we can go back you can get different
clothes you can grow your hair back out
don't pigeonhole your kid into this into
this thing
and Jamie what about the D transitionist
what about the kids who've gone through
the conveyor belt
and they've had the you know the
surgeries the medicalization they've
come out the other side they've realized
that this has all been a horrendous
mistake what happens to them
the medical establishment right now is
completely
completely ignoring them and pretending
like they don't exist
so the centers don't see them
um there really is no care provided and
I think that part of part of my hope for
centers like this is that not only do we
actually pause this
crazy experiment that's going on
but then also really focus on providing
medical support and care for all of
those kids and I also think we do need
to recognize that there are going to be
long-term outcomes that might need some
legal financial support because if you
are
like Chloe Cole and you had a double
mastectomy at 13 and you're now just now
18. the
the financial damages
for her
could not even really be calculated
probably
it would have to look at her whole
lifetime what is this done to her
fertility her her bonding with her child
her ability to breastfeed like those
things deserve a financial answer and
hopefully also that we stop doing this
to anyone else
what Jamie to read between the lines and
to summarize it in the blunt Russian way
is only I can it sounds like what you're
saying is this is a medical malpractice
Scandal on a large scale that is going
to blow up in people's faces very soon
in your opinion or should at least
should blow up in people's faces very
soon
yeah I think you kind of nailed it
well you know what when you get someone
on the show to talk about it who's you
know he's a journalist or they have an
opinion for you know they talk for a
living and whatever you sort of go well
you know are you qualified to talk about
it but you know talking to you about it
has really clarified a lot of things in
my mind because you've seen it from the
inside and you were involved in you know
working with this I suppose the one
counter argument people sometimes make
is I have heard some people who are on
board with this stuff say that oh
de-transitioners are a very small
percentage you know any medical
treatment has some people who are not
happy with the outcome if you go and
have some kind of you know if you go and
get hip replacement there's a whatever
percent failure and people get upset
that the hip didn't get replaced
correctly
to them
yes there are there are definite
medical interventions that are done that
can have poor outcomes
however this is systematic
this is almost Universal
and
this is not even touching on the
the outcomes that we are also
an outcome of somebody who's
detransitioning
but the outcome of somebody who is 13
and put on testosterone by 26 they are
potentially going to also be on a
cholesterol medication a diabetes
medication have heart complications have
an early Cardiac Arrest
um we know that these drugs just
longitudinally are not healthy good
drugs they're harsh they're hard on the
body these are hard things to
continuously have to use and so I think
part of the reason why it's
it's just a broader medical Scandal is
that
even in the best case outcome where
someone's happy with that transition
their body is still going to have
medical problems and complications from
the use of these drugs and also I think
just as a society I thought we had
gotten to the point where we were done
sterilizing kids
just I I just thought we were done doing
that
and recognize that to be its own
kind of
problematic thing that we weren't we
weren't going to be doing that anymore
Jamie and I'm also a gay person and I
just feel like we're also kind of
what are we doing to this whole group of
kids that are potentially just gay kids
the phrase people use is true you're
translating away the gay yeah
yeah
yeah well it's been an uplifting episode
but Jamie thank you so much for coming
on and for speaking openly and honestly
we everybody here Salute You bravery and
I'm sure there's going to be tens of
thousands if not hopefully hundreds of
thousands of people who are going to be
listening uh to your words and they're
going to be protecting kids and
they're going to be better informed this
to this situation before we let you go
uh the last question we ask all our
guests is what's the one thing that
we're not talking about as a society
that we really should be
it's strange but I'm going to say
homophobia
so I think that
part of the trans epidemic is that
kids did not feel and do not feel like
it's okay to be gay
and a lot of the spaces and a lot of the
support that I had as a gay kid has has
disappeared so there was a gay coffee
house there were gay bars there was a
gay culture and
it was I thought we were getting to the
point of society that it was okay to be
gay and now so many of these trans kids
tell us directly in the center that it's
it's not and that they feel like it it's
almost better to be trans and have a
lifetime of medical problems
and that means we have to go back to
square one and really deal with
homophobia
jamarie thank you so much for coming on
the show we're going to ask you a few
questions from our supporters that only
they will get to see the answers to
we're going to make sure to put a link
to the article that you published about
this and I really recommend everybody
you know sorry to use this problematic
phrase but man up and read it because
it's it's pretty pretty difficult
reading frankly but needs reading if you
want to be informed about this issue and
thank you for coming on is is there
anywhere other than the article that
people should go to to follow your work
or anything like that
um at this point no
good you're the ladai
started as a ladder and you're sticking
to your principles I love it well listen
thank you for coming on the show thank
you guys for watching and listening uh
see you on locals with the bonus
questions very very shortly
Annie says uh what does Jamie think we
need to do to stop this from continuing
where is the change going to come from
thank you